Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Resident Evil 7.
Now, we're on the Not A Hero DLC, and we've got to go into the night vision place, which means this might be a bit spooky
So put on your spoofing pants
Yeah, those look like traps, oh these are probably traps too -
tik-tok
smix smock blamady blamady
Ok I'm gonna actually try to do this right - there we go. Oh wait. Why can't I - oh there we go
Wait how many do I have now?
*Gasp* Four! Is that a good number? I guess? Alright, whatever
I'll wait till I get one more and then see what I can do with that one
Those are a lot of pressure plates on the ground there
Lukas, you planning something to do with my pressure?
I don't mind you
Planning for such things ooh OHHHH
That's right, the lockpick!
I don't know - I don't know if there was a point to that, but I got it. RAMRODs!
Finally god. I can't believe I wasted two of those bad boys. I didn't know they were so rare. Whatever, not my fault.
Oh, hey, how's it going there, buddy?
I'm just gonna slide right under there. Wouldn't it be hilarious if he pulled a prank and just spooked me by setting off my,
my wrist bomb
Ooh, *incoherent*
Oh it's a tripwire okay, I know I was about to - I was about to stand up and punch the red button. That would have ended goodly
Okay, but that's why I would have died, because I needed the night-vision, ahhhh
Ooh this looks - I don't trust that
And I don't trust that at all, but I'm gonna bullshit
Hi-yah, oh
What a kick
Woah uh-oh.
Aah! Nahnananana
Stop stop, don't. No. Yeah, that's right
Why, why are there just these
Crazy headless ones and armless. I don't like it. Yeugh, it's so scawy
No
How could it be so?
How could they have locked it? Oh no. I'm soo sad now, okay?
I didn't feel like it had enough momentum to be able to break through all those logs from that distance
But okay Chris's kick is just more powerful than I ever could have imagined - oh
*inhale*
Yeah, don't like that
No, I don't like that at all. Eugh all right. Well it's a puzzle ain't it well
Let's push these back here, so I got no means of escape
Wooooah!
Did I mention I'm Chris Redfield, and I'm a badass - what's that sound?
Something's tinkle tankling : and I'm not sure what okay. Well you need to go through vatten
*Mark making weird noises*
Okay, well alright well I got that
Hey come on now. No. Yeah, that's right you -
Eugh I don't like the way it rise - in fact I don't like much anything that riseseseses
Alright. *More noises*
Well it's full of balloons
Wow
Woo!
Okay alright that was fun. That was a fun one. Ooh hello. That was a fun one. I liked that one. Good one
Let me try this one. I don't know if it's gonna do anything
*More weird noises :D*
Well that did nothing. Alright, well, happy that happened. What's over here now
Anybody got a coin, anybody got the door? That's locked from the other side, anybody got more balloons?
Okay, whatever you say
Hi-yah!
Uh-oh
Ah that's the clown door, but I can't get to the clown door yet, ooh
*Gasp* The clown
For the clown door do you have a clown key? *More gasp*
Aah I bet you have tons of clown keys crammed in your door zone (?)
Like a clown car but a clown - door zone instead.
Clown jest with clown keys
How many clowns you got crammed into you?
Am I going crazy for saying clowns so much? Ooh antique coin didn't even see that one
Any antique clowns in there?
Alright well, I don't trust you.
Oh
No no - hate that - nop!
*Some FNAF bullshit*
Yeah, I don't like you and I definitely don't like all the nails you got there. Welp!
I'm gonna grab - ohhh
Ah!
Hey come on now no
No
Stop - being - dick
Alright, well. I got the clown key. Yeah, that's nice, so now I can revisit all the - ooh
How about no?
Man these guys are tough when you don't hit them in the face, I forgot about that quality.
Oh hey
Oh hey, wait wait wait wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa hey whoa whoa okay - alright here we go
Hey wait wait wait.
Ho-ho, ho! Ho-ho, hoooooo
No you're dead, okay, well that sucks for you, and I don't care, okay
Alright, I'll just use the shotgun for a bit, I guess
So I can't use this to unlock the door
direeeeeectly I bet
But -
Oh!
*Inhale*
Would it consume it?
I bet I bet I bet I don't know what's telling me yes
but I bet that it's
Better to take this key back to the center and use it there to unlock all the doors
If that is how this works which it may not
And then maybe that's gonna unlock all of them whereas if I did that that I was just there
Maybe it only would have done one of them
Maybe - and then again, maybe not maybe I'm crazy, but I'm gonna go back any - whoa oh, I can't, never mind
I'm not gonna do that thing and my theory is good but my execution is bullshit
so I'm gonna go over here and use it on this door.
Ah I see okay, ah it was -
Ah
Ooh - whoa
Alright who wants some? Huh? Want some? Hello, uh-oh. LIMBOOOO!
Ah
Lobotomy
Wait I just got that heavy feeling of traps you know, I don't like a heavy feeling of traps
I mean obviously there's traps, but I think there's might be other traps
Okie, real sneaky
Channeling my inner Tom Cruise
Euh! In Mission Impossible - okay, that was good. Mission Possible - waagh!
Wait a -
Who the -
What?
Well that guy's dead. Why - I didn't even notice that guy that guy is so dead
Hmm, okay, alright, well. One false move and this guy is dunzo
probably
Yeah, he - oh are you breathin'? No? A little bit. Maybe - yeah, he movin' okay, alright
He's still alive but not for long
Definitely not for long, okay, alright
Ooh
*Inhale* Yeeeeeeep
Okay good job standing up before you get down you idiot. Okay, okay, okay? Alright alright
Ooh
Ah like a butterfly
Ooh what is this? Shotgun ammo perfect!
Anything up on the uppers?
Uppers? No, okay, alright. Well - here I come body on this precarious plank
*Incoherent*
How you doing?
You were one of our best right?
Uh-oh
Naaaaaaah!
Ow - what the hell?
Ohhhhhhhhhh
Okay
Well alright, then I didn't know that - ah okay. Saving your fellow soldier while the traps are still active is dangerous. Well. How did I know?
De - It's not like you gave me much of a - yaaa!
Screw you you know screw you - oh, oh I gotta go all the way from the beginning NO!
I'm coming Chris Redfield like a lumbering behemoth in the night
Imma lumber my way over here to you
alright
I'm not even gonna try to be careful.
Aah how the hell you - ?
How the hell was I supposed to know that he'd have a remote control over it, huh?
Freakin' douche - alright I'll get you in a second I guess. Euh I didn't know I was supposed to do this god
It's not like there's rules here so shut up asshole. Alright. What about this?
Habooski!
Kerchunkles?
Ah that's the good stuff, okay, alright
Well I did that - was there a way to deactivate the traps for the other guys? Can I just leave? Heuh can I just leave?
Don't leave your comrade? Oh
Sure, okay. Alright. Yeah, okay
Yeah, this ain't gonna work out so well for you I imagine
Okay, why are you groaning so much? What's wrong with your butt? Why are you grabbing it like that?
Okay, you got some hip displacement? Alright sure whatever you say
Ooh
Yeah, I'm sure you're gonna get out of this alive
Okay alright, well this is bad. Well jeez, at least he gave me a ten minute timer. Guess my friends didn't get the same
Ooh
luxury
Wait - wooh oh yeah wait hang on. You go, you - you go. You go ahead. I got time
Oh no, what happened to you? - Wham.
Alright, I'm going I'm going I'm going alright. I'm going
Golly gee ohhh hey, hey, don't step on the whoa don't st - hey. Don't step on the thing - uh-oh
He's stepping on the thing - ooh he's not stepping on the thing
Alright, well he laying on the thing, that's gotta count for somethin' - alright. We got through there, alright
Yeah?
Okay
Okay, whatever you say let me save so that I don't DIE a horrible DEATH
From the explosion - disease - you have to deactivate - oh come on! I don't have to deactivate the bomb first
What do ya - what are you a big baby? Come on I can do both. I can multitask come on, please
Hmm. How about no? Oh shoot
How did he - ? What? Nooo, come on!
Get off my face hey you - nah
Eh - no - eh
No, okay, alright. Cya. See you guys. Well that guy's dead. Alright well Imma run along
Imma skeloodilidoo over to here. Go up this place. Whatever have you
Cya buddies
Kind of got a bomb next to me. Why would he give m -
Why would you give me a timer and not them? That doesn't make any s - unless they had a timer already and they were out of time
I'm not 100% sure. And why does it - why does it match up with my own heads-up display? That ma - that makes even less sense
Is it over here?
No, still over here?
*Weird noise* Where the hell?
Well I don't know where I'm going. Why don't I have a map on this thing? Ooh. Hey hey wait wait wait wait wait wait, buddy
*Laughs*
That get -  makes me laugh every time I laugh every time
oh
Wait another one okay that's no good. Alright hang on hang on hang on
Alright - wait is there a crawler skittering after me? Oh yeah, there are
But I need to switch to the other cuz I need a
Ssss - ahhhh
Precision. Oh no he's dead. Never mind - heuh no precision. Oh where am I going? Oh the clown door. I've got a clown key.
Oh okay, I get it. I forgot that I could just unlock them. Alright I got you
Loud or clunky, let's go. Clown town
Grenades that I haven't been using - oh, I do not have the bullets for you
Ahhhhhhhhhhh
Scram. I could have just run for it, I guess
Hello, anybody here? Bullets
Ooh okay
Alright, where did this go? This is where I wanted to be
Liquid nitrogen? Hello? Well, I got an antique coin. I guess that's the best of both worlds - helloh?
Hello? The hell am I going?
*Gasp* Ohhh
The other way, the way - oh, that's big and bright. How did I miss that? Okay, alright
Well at least I found the secret area. Hi-yeah! Aw sweet! I got super juice gu - aw nine of 'em
Yes, oh am I gonna need them?
Okay?
So uh, what's stopping me from - ?
Getting to that room? You think it's gonna be zombies? You think there's gonna be ramrod zombies? Just scouting around
I'm sure I have time
Okay,
I - I'm gonna be real pissed if le - ooh
I don't wanna eat shit and die
Aww they're outhouses.
Uh-oh
Hey buddy
Eugh
Very lovely.
Oh
Do I punch him? Hi-yah!
*Laughs*
Yeah sure ok let's go with that one. Yeah, that's that's great. I love his split head brain
Oh
boom, uh-oh. Ow
He just belly smacked me. Ya douche thanks for waiting for me to get back up
Ah! What the hell?
You freakin' douche you're not gonna let - oh god. I gotta, alright heal - run run run ok
Alright come on come on come on come on
Hey
I don't know if a grenade will work on him
I want to punch you again
Well I'm out of those, so what do I do now?
Owww!
Well alright then how about I just shove this in your gob?
Hi-yeeeeeee
Oh, oh, oh, I'm gonna punch. I'm gonna punch. I'm gonna punch. Punch
Heee-yabooski!
Oh shit dude. Take another one of these for the road
Ah-yeeeeee
Another one?
Alright there - owoah! Uh-oh! Ooh did I get him? Wait. Wait. Did he go down? *Gasp* Wait? I'm a bunch a -
Hang on - wait wait wait wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait wait wait - euh!
Habooski! Rule threes baby. You dead? You done? You done for? Oh, you don't look done.
Uh-oh. I'm out! I'm out! Euhhhh!
Oh wait there's something over there. Hang on. Wait. Hang on. Please, wait. Wait.
Uh-oh, here we go. Ring around the rosy. Pocket full of posy - this is a waste of ammo, but I hope it's alr - awoah!
Eugh! Gross
Ooh oh oh ohhhhh! That's not good -  hang on wait. Oh geez oh jesums. Oh jesums - firebomb. Imma firebomb you guys. Ooh firebomb firebomb firebomb.
Boom!
Like a Molotov, but even better apparently. Oh god I hate that. Well that's - that's no good - yep. Hate that
Why aren't you just lighting on f - woah hey!
Oh, woah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah you let me give that punch. Hi-yabooski! Bro force, or somethin'.
Woah woah woah woah woah ramrod!
Alright, okay
Yeah, I'll just go through this outhouse. Excuse me. Knock knock, anybody home?
Alright cya, okay
Hey convenient *laughs* convenient. Alright just dip my hand in there
Whole hand just dip it in yes, sure, okay
Yeah, throw it, you, dumbass. Shit! Oh God, it's so dangerous
And apparently I'm supposed to take him alive or something
The shield machine you say
You mean like the drill in the mine?
The shield machi - ah god I did it again. God I don't know why even that time I wasn't even trying to crouch
Alright, whatever. There's another clown room in the other area
I kind of want to go find, but I don't know if it'll be worth it, but I kind of want to go find it
It'd be nice to get all those clowns. I don't know if it's like some super special bonus or nuttin', but I might -
Alright, what do we got?
Anybody gonna mess with me? It's amazing how much havoc Lucas can wreak like Ethan went through these mines himself
Why didn't Lucas waste his time on him?
I mean he tried to kill him before but his machinations didn't work, and he had enough time to move his clown, buddy
Oh well, whatever
Alright, I'm gonna go, to the other one and I'm gonna check out the other clown door before I go to this one
Just because I can and I'm kind of like wanting to be thorough about this. Hi-yeh, let me through please
*Weird noise* Thank you, okay. I think he was down here
I think it was just around the corner on the inside, so I don't think I have to go very far about it
But also why did he hide the clown doors? A lot of what he does doesn't make it - oh it's right, right here, okay, alright clown door, clown
Clowny, what do you got for me, baby?
Euh clowny ooh
Okay
Ooh well I guess that was worth it. Got stabilizer out there, I think that's like one of those permanent upgrades isn't it? Yeah
Jimmimimy
Sweet, and I think I got enough coins to do everything else, so why not? My reload speed increased. That's super useful right now probably
Maybe a little bit probably I think a lot, maybe. I'm not 100% sure about that, but yeah, I'm gonna go with yeahh
I want to go with a whole lot of yeah, okay, alright. Anyway. Where is it again?
Oh who's up here? Yeah that's right, okay?
I got it. Nobody worry about anything. Alright, so once I get these I'm gonna activate the clown there because
Apparently he gave away for us to get him. I don't know why. Steroids increased max health indefinitely
Wait, oh wait. I don't have enough for both
Stabilizer reload speed increases indefinitely
I - I'd rather every load speed than the other one, maybe I'll get more later
Ok - uh, I gotta do it one at a time
Oh man, why does this family love their ancient coins so much
Alright, I guess that was worth it if it was worth five so, got that
Ooh wait! How do I get  - ? There were steroids and that in there? *Gasp* nice
Okay, alright. I'll take both. Yeah. Give me that - steroids
Yeah, this is how Chris - this is how Chris got in trouble
He was just constantly jamming steroids and
Stabilizers in his arms. He's got the steadiest roidiest hand
Yeah that's a drill not a shield. That's a drill drill baby drill I guess but that's a drill
Okay. Alright
Glad I did that
Okay
Alright. You can stop now, very scary big machine. So - ooh. Wah come on. now is not the time for that, really?
Ah
Oh there we go. Pff
Saving - what? No you stupid only five save slots what am I gonna do with five save slots?
Nothing, that's what I'm gonna do. Alright. Let's go. I don't care what he - my addiction is doing get outta here
Shouldn't even be in friends
Hey, how's it going in here?
Get ramrod
Those things, this, that, splip splap, okay. Well I seem to be gearing me up for a battle of some sorts
I'm gonna keep this with the ramrod ammo, and I'm gonna keep this with the not ramrod ammo
Dark in here
No night vision huh?
Okay. Ooh, woah!
No. No
No, how do you - uh - h - wha - what, what are you controlling these things? How are you doing that? How are you doing that Lucas?
Are you sending them out all at once? *Incoherent* Woah!
Hey, heeeey
Don't - stop
Believing
Hold on to that feeling - oh hey. You're pouring out of the ceiling. Uh-oh, this is why I kept you and you
Alright so far so goo
Yeah, how are you sending these guys out Lucas, I don't understand how you have any sort of control over any of this. Wooh
That's a lot of goop raining down on my face, and I don't like it
Dude you don't even know who I am - whoa, hey what the hell?
Get your head out here. Whoa. Well that ain't good. I don't like the way that looks
Oh this is easy. I thought you're gonna give me a challenge here. Hold on your head. Hold on your torso. Come on.
Oh god you son of a bitch. No! Oh, you
Haha!
Got him
It's just a body shot for them, so it's nothing even too bad
Oh your head! Hahaha
I don't even need to aim with this thing
Uh, not really man
I dunno, probably a lot. Uh-oh
Huh
Owwww!
Don't do that don't do that hey take your grenade
Uh-oh
Oww
Hey, I realize - I didn't even throw the grenade - woah-oh. Well this is bad.
Oh come on. This is gross
This is disgusting
Alright, take one of these now. Woah-oh he's doing the thing. He's doing the thing he's gonna blow!
Oh. Well because he didn't blow
Alright well. Still gonna do a lot of this
Ah come on. Oh titty sprinkles come on. Alright now you're dead okay good, finally
Is that the sound of him dying or - ooh he didn't die okay, alright, well. Oh what the hell happened there?
I don't know. What was that?
Uh-oh
Uh-oh - ow what - wha - what's hitting me?
Uh-oh euuuuuhh he's gonna blow up
Alright well that was easy. Imma take one of these just as a victory - uh, roid
Uh-oh
Ooh, found it. Barely. Oh no no I didn't
Yeah, I agree with that sentiment
Sure yeah, okay
Yeah, well that's how I'm gonna get away. We're watching so you don't know
Hi-yaa I'm so strong. Uh-oh
No
Come on now. Come on. Just let me sweet talk just great here hey, come on, what are you -
You know I might - I'm markiplier by the way. Did you know that? I bet you didn't know that, okay down I go wee
5? Oh
Ohhhhhhhh
Well that's not good
Well, I'd probably be worried about this if I didn't have an absolute certainty that I was gonna get away from it. Weeee. Oh hey fire
I don't really need night vision down here. It's very burny, very bright
Okay, I guess I do. Alright sure, let's go with that. Huh. Where else are you gonna send me?
Can't go that way
NOOOOO!
I'm emotionally traumatized
Oh okay, well I didn't find another uh, I didn't find any other
Lockpicks, where the hell am I? I just went out of the mines and into some facility
I thought I was at the Baker farm. Why am I over here?
How did I get over here?
Also, where is here? The only thing that was nearby would have been the boat, and it's definitely not, the boat
Whoa
Hey, buddy
Okay, don't mind me. Oh yeah I got the bullets for them, but I don't want to go and disturb them
Okay, that's weird. Ooh scawy
Okay
Nice clown thing okay. Oh, this is his lab where he was doing teeests, okay, I get it
Okay, well I'll just have to take care of him. Ooh, clean room, no need
Ooh hey buddy
Oh do (?)
Oh do (???)
Oh do (!!!!!) Ooh hey. Whoa wait whoa wait whoa wait whoa. How are you under that bed? That doesn't even make any sense
How are you under that bed?
I feel like I would have seen you. What did I just get? Did I get a lock picker? Ah med thing. Ooh, creepy
Weh - WOOOOOAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Okay alright then
Alright
*Inhale* ooooWOOOAAAAAAAAAAOOOOOOOOOOOO
Okay this was for Evelyn I guess. Why was everyone down here?
Oh look at that. Look at that. Oh what a happy family. Yeah sure okay. I live here. What did I just get?
I never know what I get before I get them. I guess I got anti those things bullets? Yeah, okay, alright
I don't know whose blood that is. But, alright. Well. I guess I'm out of here. Cya!
Cya!
Cya.
It's probably some story to be gleaned from that but I'm not 100% sure what they're trying to say. Okay, got those
Alright well moving on. Ah-yee, anyway, actually I am actually all
I know I'm probably close to the end of this, but you know what I'm gonna carry on y'know what carry on you gonna get up?
Yeah, yeah, yeah you were
Alright cya. I haven't been able to punch anybody. I'm sick of this guy Lucas
They just gave him my job as lead researcher
Who do they think I am? Why do I -
A Stanford graduate with a master's in microbiology - have to work under this lunatic? All he does is mess around with the test subjects - making them
All fight each other and doing unnecessary
Autopsies. He's sick. He knows nothing about the E-series mutamycete's potential. I'm gonna report his behavior at the next HQ meeting
Alright, well, na pff, I wonder how that worked out for you buddy owner whose blood this is now
So there were other people working in this facility? That was near the Baker's?
So like this whole facility was set up here just for the Baker's benefit. Is that what I'm supposed to believe here?
I'm gonna go to the other ammo because I want to use the pistol a little bit, no power. Of course there's no
Lucas can I shoot you in the back of the heeead?
Hey buddy
Hey Lucas
How do you not notice me Lucas? Ludi Lucas?
Lucas
Alright, actually. I'm all out time for this episode, so I'm gonna end this one here
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you think down the comments below. And as always, I'll see you, in the next video
BYE BYEEEEEE :D